so it's not rude um  so i actually asked my dad what the  answer to this question was because i  wasn't sure  i wasn't sure exactly but this is going  to be a ballpark and just a disclaimer  it cost way more than he thought it  would and he said he would never do it  again so he said the slide itself cost  20k and that's without the  transportation  to build it was 25k on the first try and  there's a lot of unsuccessful attempts  of the motors that i guess the slide guy  said would work but didn't  and then he finally purchased a 15 hp  motor they did not have a phase three  power i don't know what that means um we  stopped counting but we figure at least  50k  and then the cost of the fiberglassing  joint the joints of the slide is 2k per  year i don't even know what i'm reading  well it looks like about 55k and he said  he would never do it again so